un ramassage d'ordure jusqu'à deux fois
plus cher ces habitants de jargeot n'en
veulent pas ce matin dans le cortège un
seul mot d'ordre non à la redevance
incitative c'est
carrément prohibitif comme prix écoutez
moi le service est divisé par 4 et la
facture multipliée par un 5 cette
redevance est mise en place pour inciter
les usagers à trier davantage leurs
déchets mais selon l'association Adus à
l'origine de la manifestation de ce
matin les tarifs appliqués découragent
les
citoyens dans redevance incitative il y
a une connotation d'inciter donc qui dit
incité on part du principe que les
usagers doivent être récompensés donc
notre combat il est contre la grille
tarifaire qui est conjointe à cette
redevance incitative la redevance sera
effective au 1er janvier prochain d'ici
là l'association Adus espère voir les
tarifs
[Applaudissements]
renégociés pour